even if you have all world you're gonna
die
everything is gonna be finished one day
and
and uh a couple people gonna come to
grave
put you inside them and finish
you know that's why i i don't wanna i
don't wanna put
like crazy goal in front of me you know
like very soon i think like soon my
career gonna finish
of course this is i'm not on beginning
my way and
soon is gonna be finished and i'm gonna
beginning my new life
you know without all this like
interview without all this like with
media stuff like weight cutting
hard training like focusing i'm gonna
beginning like
new life and uh and for life i don't
need
i don't need like too much you know even
even if you billionaire you never eat
more than one bread in one day
you know that's why it's like uh
i want i i wanna be free i wanna fly and
i wanna do whatever i want whatever i
need
whatever i need when i die because i
really believe to next life
and it's gonna uh everything what you
did
everything what you're gonna do
in next life
you have to do something what important
for you in next life
you know like my father always talked
about this with me
like he always tried to do something
good for people
around him and for people
from his country from his village
from for his family he always do
something and and he always say i hope
this is gonna help me for next life
and
you